on pêche sur la glace dans très peu de
pays au monde et le canada est l'un
d'eux pourtant malgré la popularité de
cette activité et son importance
culturelle on connaît peu les effets de
cette pêche sur la ressource au québec
le ministère des forêts et de la faune
et des parcs veut corriger le manque de
connaissances entourant ce qu'on appelle
la pêche blanche
chaque hiver des milliers de pêcheurs et
pêcheuse brave le vent et le froid sur
la glace à partir du mois de janvier des
centaines de cabanes ponctuent le
paysage du fjord du saguenay pour
quelques semaines
directement ici on pêche vraiment les
paires l'arc en ciel on peut voir là il
ya vraiment village qui sur le bord qui
concentrait pour la pêche à l'éperlan
arc en ciel parce que c'est vraiment une
espèce christine dans des eaux peu
profondes par pêcheur on a droit à 120
et pearl
vous avez
qu'est ce
qui
en fait pour être sûr qu'il n'y pas de
cap là non plus ce qu'on veut c'est
l'hyper l'art donc je prends un poisson
j'en ai parlé à la fois je mesure ça
c'est un bourg
150,7
avec les écailles en est capable de
savoir de déterminer un âge puis avec la
taille et là on est capable d'aller plus
loin dans l'analyse des populations
la popularité et l'accessibilité de la
pêche en hiver dans le fjord engendre
une importante pression de pêche
pour en mesurer l'effet sur les perdants
arc en ciel le ministère des forêts de
la faune et des parcs du québec em ffp
suis l'exploitation de la ressource il
note le nombre de poissons pêchés par
jour et par personne c'est ce qu'on
appelle le succès de pêche
depuis 2006 on a suivi on vient voir les
pêcheurs trois fois par semaine on les
enquêtes justement pour savoir c'est
quoi leur succès de pêche on prend aussi
des données biologiques pour avoir un
petit peu d'indicateurs pour savoir
comment se portent les populations nous
on a fait le choix de faire un suivi sur
cette espèce là parce qu'elle est
vraiment importante au niveau économique
et écologique au niveau régional mais on
veut aussi s'assurer que cette
population venue dans le temple qui va
l'exploitation va être durable
cheney
avait tout fâché de le faire aujourd'hui
pour les paires l'arc-en-ciel là c'est
clair noté évident avec la pression de
pêche pendant la période estivale est
beaucoup plus faible que pendant la
période hivernale c'est vraiment une
activité beaucoup plus importante en
hiver ici car marc l'été
malgré l'importance culturelle de la
pêche sur glace au québec peu de régions
peuvent s'enorgueillir d'un suivi comme
celui fait au saguenay
à l'échelle de la province l'ampleur de
la récole de poissons en hiver est
inconnue à sainte anne de la pérade la
capitale historique de la pêche aux
poulamons très fréquenté la dernière
estimation des prélèvements date de 1979
évidemment faut faire des choix là dans
les suivis confins oui des endroits puis
à des populations qui sont moins bien
suivi parce qu'on peut pas se permettre
de suivre l'ensemble des populations ça
redevienne système peu d'études
interroge les conséquences de la pêche-
hivernale sur les stocks de poissons
contrairement à la pêche estivale
devant ces lacunes le m ffp a décidé de
commencer par répertorier les sites de
pêche hivernale dans la province en
abitibi témiscamingue
le dernier inventaire datée de 1996
balfour le but c'est vraiment de
s'assurer de faire une saine gestion des
populations de dorel dont on veut
s'assurer que les lacs ne sont pas
surexploiter à fonction de la longueur
d'oreilles capable de déterminer l'âge
normalement on survole à tous 20 langues
la région il ya deux parcours puis est
ce qu'on fait l'enfant sait qu'on va
survoler pour contre les groupes de
pêcheurs sur chacun des lacs on prend
note le type d'armé le nombre de
motoneige participent d'abris le nombre
de personnes aussi par type d'abus puis
avec le deuxième volet en motoneige sur
le terrain est en mesure de faire une
estimation des dogues sont conservés par
personne puis on veut pour extrapoler
saint lô lac ont inventorié le par avion
assure toi c'est de couvrir une bonne
partie de la région
chaque région a ses particularités sur
les lacs de l'abitibi on est loin du
tumulte des villages de pêche du fjord
du saguenay le plus grand site de pêche
hivernale de la province
1752 cabane prennent vie en ce début
d'année 2022 un record depuis le début
de leur recensement en 1998 on en
comptait déjà un millier à la b2 village
éphémère de pêche sur glace regroupe
plus d'habitants que plusieurs
municipalités de la région
on le sait en moyenne que ces minima 2.5
peschard par cabannes 2500 personnes sur
le village ça peut des fois être plus à
peu des fois être moins et ça c'est sans
compter toutes les gens qui vont à
l'extérieur du village donc des gens
pour y aller en motoneige en quatre
roues qui vont pêcher un petit tente ou
en cavale portative qui se comptent à
plusieurs centaines également la ville
de labé a confié la gestion des deux
villages à l'organisme contact nature la
majorité des personnes qui sont sur le
village ils viennent de la région donc
environ 70% donc ceux qui louent déterré
et ceux qui vont louer des cabanes vélo
c'est principalement des gens de
l'extérieur donc les gens de montréal de
québec et des genres que de partout
beaucoup de personnes de l'europe aussi
qui vont venir pour vivre l'expérience
de la peuplent
on
au niveau social il ya toute une vie qui
prend forme autour de la pêche blanche
serait vraiment partie de la culture
maintenant
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à pêcher sur la glace du
fort à l'âge de 7 ou 8 ans j'ai jamais
perdu cette passion la même car atteint
pourtant moins de pêcher ici de voir que
des milliers de personnes se soient pas
comme moi dans leur cabane ça m'émeut
beaucoup
lucile soixantaine d'espèces de poissons
mais ce qui est excitant la plus c'est
peut-être pas savoir ce qu'on vous
rattrapez vous savez ça coûte le malade
la particularité du fjord c'est qu'on
retrouve aussi bien des poissons d'eau
douce qui vivent en surface comme les
perles en arc en ciel et des poissons
d'eau salée qui vivent en profondeur
comme le sébaste ou l'amoureux et yeux
sont gérés par le ministère pêches et
océans canada
à mes débuts dans les années 80 la
présence du poisson dans l'enseigné est
très impressionnante
pour faisait vraiment dit delpech
attraper
une bonne limite de sébaste de la morue
sur hbo c'était même pas des filles
c'est incroyable puis par la suite on a
vu
l'ajout de poissons diminuent et on le
fait des efforts parce que on est parti
à l'époque de pas de limite à 25 poisson
à 15 poissons sont à cinq poissons
qui pèche aux siens canada après son ont
réduit la saison de pêche pour donner
une chance à la ressource parce qu' on
était inquiet même année pas aucagne et
d'avoir la fermeture de la page
[Musique]
donc on l'a vu le poisson a diminué puis
bah non je peux vous dire une chose est
revenu le poisson
un petit saint vaast
c'est le poisson le plus recherché si l
apej large tout le monde m'a la petite
ville du civa d'en profiter là
lorsque les villages prennent vie en
fait c'est tout les commerçants et les
restaurants on sent que l'hiver commence
vraiment là aussi un bel engouement on
estime que c'est à plus de 5.5 millions
de dollars que ton économie plus juste
pour l'habit et ça c'est juste les
retombées des villages si on compare la
semaine avec ça s'installe
par rapport à la semaine qui sont
installés ces 20 % d'augmentation
nous vivons ça fait l'hôte hiver puis je
pense que pour la région c'est vraiment
les plus le garde
[Musique]
manger très bonne génération
commence à être concernant les autres
années est beaucoup plus petit
pour certaines espèces de poissons la
pêche hivernale est néfaste au point
d'être interdite c'est le cas du touladi
et de l'omble de fontaine le ministère
conclut qu'à l'instar la pêche estivale
il est impératif de bien comprendre les
effets de la pêche- hivernale et de les
considérer dans la gestion des espèces
exploitées
en ayant une démonstration de
l'importance de l'activité puis la
sensibilité aussi des populations on est
capable apprécié de pouvoir mieux là
pour la protéger leurs cadres et puis
s'assurer que les populations au pouvoir
demeure y à long terme
[Musique]
en 2019 le ministère a répertorié 4739
cabane dans le saint laurent et ses
affluents les résultats de l'inventaire
en abitibi-témiscamingue seront connus
dans deux ans environ mais il reste
encore beaucoup de travail à faire
d'ailleurs pour la première fois depuis
2003 le ministère a prévu un suivi des
prélèvements annuels au lac saint pierre
lorsqu'on a véhicules des années plus
difficiles qu'on voit des années comme
ça que ça devienne des gens ce qu'ils
disent c'est que protégeons la ressource
pensons à demain de puiser mais ça
épuise et s'être cette ressource marine
de dsd que s'il ya une chute dans la
ressource si une chose d'à la qualité le
page mais c'est tout le monde autour de
la communauté qui voit sera recensée